♪ ♪>> Sean: N AND FASCINATING
DEVELOPMENTS TO NTH IN THE
BIDEN OPERA BORDERRISIS AS
FAILG D.C. MAYOR MURIEL BOWSERNS
ARE CROWNING D. HOMELESS
SHELTERS
SHE CIMS THEY ARE BEING
TRICD INTO HOPPING ON BUSES TO
E NATION'S CAPAL.
SHE'S UPSET ABOUT IT.
TAKEOOK.
>> THIS IS A VERY SIGNIFICANT
ISSU
WE CALLEON THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TOORK ACROSS STATELIE
FROM BEING TRICKED INTGETTING
ON BUSES.
WE TNK THEY ARE LARGELY
ASYLUMEEKERS WHO WERE GOI TO
FINAL DESTINATIONS AT ARE NOT
WASHINGTON, D.C.
I WORKED WITH T WHITE HOUSE TOMA
GRANT TO AOCAL ORGANIZATION
THAT'S PVIDING SERVICES TO
FOLKS.
BUT I FEAR EY ARE BEING
TRICKED INTO BUS TRIPS WHEN THE
FIL DESTINATIONS ARE PLACE
ALL OVERHE UNITED STATES OF
AMICA.
>> Sn: TRANSLATION, SHE
DOESN'T WANT THE IN THE
NATION'S CAPIT.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTTAS BEEN
STDING UP TO BIDEN'S BORDER
DISASTER AND LAWLESSNESS
YEP, BUSSING THE MIGRANTS RIGHT
TO BIDEN'S DOORSTEP IN D.C.
MAYBE MURIEL BOWR WILL GET A
OK ATHAT BORDER COMMUNITS
IN TEXAS HAVE BEE DEALING WITH
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
TEXAS GOVERNOAND EVERY OTHER
BOER STATE GOVERNOR NEEDS TO
NOW DO THE SAME TNG.
EVERY SINGLE ILLEG IMMIGRANT
AIDED AND ETTED BY JOE BIDEN
WHO IS NOT ENFORCIN FEDERAL LAW
AND SENDING THEM OUT TOWASHINGTE
- SENDTHEM ALL TO WASHINGTON, .
TE HEGSETH, ALSO LAND NUMBER
ONON THE LIST, AND OF COUE
FORMER TREASURY OICIAL MONICA
CROWLEY.
I LOVE IT.
IF SHE SAYING WE DON'T WANT T
TH.
THEN SHE ADDED ON TOP,HEAID
BY THEAY, NO, LOCAL TAXPAYERS
SHOULD NOT BEORCED TO PAY THE
BILL FOR THIS.
EVERY OTHER BORDER STE HAS
BEEN PAYING THE BL AND DEALING
WITH TS PROBLEM BAUSE
E BIDEN IS AIDING ANABETTING
THEAWBREAKING.
>> RIGHT AER THE SENTENC SHE
SAIDE NEED A COORDINATED
FEDERALESPONSE.
YOU THINK?
MAY BE ON THE BDER PROTECT THE
BORDER, I' BEEN WANTING
GR ABBOTT TO DECLARE AN
INVASION THAT GIS
CONSTITUTIONALLY THETATE OF
TEXAS JUDICIALOWER.
I WASOWNPLAYING WHAT HE WAS
SAYING ON BUSNG OF ILLEGS IN
D.C.
LES SEND HIMO DELAWARE AS
WELL.
THEY ARE NOT BEING TCKED, THE
ARE BEING KED, VOLUNTEERING TO
DO WASHINGTON, D.C AS A
RESULT.
THEY ARE FLOODED IN SWAB AND
ADMITTING WT WE KNE ABOUT BIG
TY ELITISTS.
WE WCOME MIGRANTS AND ILLEGALS
AS LON AS THEY ARE ISOMEONE
ELSE'S BACKYARD.
IF THEY ARE FODING OURSERVICES.
WHAT DOOU TNK TEXAS AND
ARIZONA, NEW MEXICO, OKLOMA,
WHAT DO YOU THINK THO STATES
E FACING?
ONE OF THE BESTXAMPLES W HE
SEEN OF THCOMPLETE DOUBLESTANDA.
IF SHE SAID ITN TV FORS.
>> Sea FOR ME, IT'S THE
PERFECT STREGY BECAUSE IT'S
THE ONLY FINALHING THATOT
THE DEMOCRATS ATTTION.
INSTITUTIONALIZE AN END I
AGREE WITH PETE'S POINT ON THEDT
MONICA.
BUT I THINK WE -- AS A MATTER OF
FACT I TNK TEXAS SHOULD SUCK
IT UP AND GIVE EVERY ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT GETTING ON THE BUS AND
INCENTIVE.$50 PER PERSO SO WHENT
TO D., THEY AT LEAST CAN GET A
GO NIGHT'S SLEEP, GET SOME
OD, AND ENJOY THE BEAUTIF
CAPITAL LEUNDER D.C.
MAYOR BOWSER.
I WOULD ADD TO, SEAN, TO THE
$50 AND I ULD GIVE EACH OF
THEM DIRECTIONS TO
NANCY PELOSI'S HOME, MURIEL
BOWSER'S HOME.
E WHITE HOUSE
CAPITOL HILL, --
>> Sean: MONICA, NOW Y'RE
DOXXING LIKE THE SREME COURT
JUSTIC, YOU WANT TO GIVE OUT
THE ADDRESSES OF THE SUPREME
COURT OFCIALS?
>> THE WHITE HOUSE, AOC, OTHER
DEMOCRATS ARE FINE WITH THAT.
THIS IS THEIRULES.
IF WE ARE PLAYINGY THEIR
LES.
THEY LAID IT OUT AND WE WILL
AY THE SAME GAME.
THE BOER STATES LIKE TEXAS AND
ARIZONA HAVE HAD IT WITH THE
INVASION.
IT'S A CRIMINALNVASION, NOT
JUST O THE STATES B THE
ENTIRE COUNTRY.
THOSE GOVERNORS HAVE DECID
THAT THEY'VE HAD ENOUGH, THEIR
PELE HAD ENOHND THEY'VE
BORNE THE BNT OF THE CRIMINAL
ACTIVITY.
THEY ARE SAYING ENOUGH.
WE ARE GOING TO NOW INFLICT T
CONSEQUEES OF
WASHINGTON, D.C.,'S ACTION ONTOY
DUING THEM RIGHT ON THE
DOORSTEP.
I WOULD TAKE IT A STEP FURTHER.
GOVERNOR RON DeSANTITALKED
ABOUT IF ANY OF THOSE ILLEGALS
COME TO FLORIDA,E WILL MOVE
THEM TO DELAWARE AND DP THEM
ON THE STREEOF JOE BIDEN'S
HOUSE.
WHERE TED CRUS IDEA, SHIP THEM
TO MARTHA'SINEYARD AND PUT
THEM ON BACK OBAMA'S FRONT
LAWN.
YOU WI SEE THE DEMOCRATS
ITCH GEAR LIKE TT BECAUSE
YOU KNOW WHAT, THE BIGGEST SPLIT
IN T COUNTRIESETWEEN THE
RUNG CLASS AND EVERYBODY ELSE.
THE RULING CSSHAT MAKES ALL
E CATASTROPHIC DECISNS THAT
THE REST OF US VE TO LIVE
WITH.
THOSE BORDERTATES A SAYING
ENOUGHND I THINK IT'S LONG
PAST TIME AND GOOFOR THEM.
>> Sn: YES OR NO, I WILL ASKYOU.
OF ON MANY FINANCIAL ISSUES,THER
PEOPLE'S MONEY
WHAT ABOUT A LIBAL ADOPT AN
ASYLUM SEEKER PROGRAM THA WE
COULD FUND FOR LIBALS AND THEY
CAN ADOPT AND ASYLUM-SEEKER IN
THE UNTRY ILLEGALLY AND THEY
CAN LIVE WITH THE STARTING WITH
NANCY PELOSI A CHUCK SCHUMER
AND COMPANY.
IT WOU THAT BE A GOOD IDEA?
>> YES, TL ME WHERE T SENDTHE M.
>> Sean: ALL THE BOOKS YOU'R
SELLING, BEING NBER ONE ON
HE NEW YORK TIMES," YOU'RE
RICH NOW.
MONICA, LAST WORD.
>> YEAH, NO, LOOK, I AGREE.
THE OF US WHO A BEARING THE
BRUNT OF ALL THESE CATASOPHIC
POLIES MIRROREDHE OTHERSIDE.
MAKE THE LIVE WITH THE
NSEQUENCES THAT THEARE
INFLICTING ON THE REST OF US.
>> Sean: THIS ISIKE DIVINE
JUSTICE.ALL OF A SUDDE IT HAPPEO
THEM.
THFIRST REACTION IS TS IS
OUAGEOUS, WE CAN HAVE THIS.
WE C'T AFFORD TO PAY FOR TS.
TO PAY FOR THIS.
THIS IS WHY TEXAS